[Music]
[Applause]
january chris mannix sports illustrated
senior
nba writer if you didn't see the game
last night chris
how would you describe it and the
importance of it
uh i would describe it as
revealing at least in terms of what the
nets
need to work on moving forward
i'm not at all concerned about the
ability of
you know kyrie james harden kevin durant
to put up points i mean they scored 96
in that game i think they scored like
42 of the last 57 points for brooklyn in
that game they'll
they'll find a way to make it work
offensively but
there were a couple of things that that
really stood out
one the nets don't defend anybody and
this has been
you know going on for most of the season
cleveland came into that game
with the 30th ranked offense like they
stunk
and they were without darius garland
they were without kevin love
and they still put 147 on brooklyn in
double overtime that
that needs to be addressed they don't
have a defensive stopper on the
perimeter
deandre jordan's best years as a rim
protector
are probably behind him they don't have
anybody off the bench that provides
uh that type of presence and they don't
really trust anybody
on that bench i mean steve nash i guess
nominally played
a nine-man rotation but you know joe
harris played 42 minutes off the bench
nobody else played more than 12.
meanwhile kevin durant
who is not that far removed from from an
ac or an achilles tear
played 50 minutes you know james harden
in his third game with the nets played
50s third straight with
40 plus kyrie irving off for two weeks
goes for 45.
you know steve nash either needs to
start trusting
the guys on his bench for sean marx has
to go out there and find a way to get
him guys if he does
yeah i think you're going to have
scoring and then defense is going to be
optional
and i think you have to have a concept
for defense and then you have to have a
willingness to want to play defense as
well
it feels like kevin durant is the one
guy who can play defense or will play
defense but trying to add to your roster
at this point in the season or later in
the season what's the uh
feasibility of that chris not much
at this point during the season i mean
you can
scour the g-league when they get started
in early february to see if anybody
kind of fits that mold um their trade
options are extremely limited because of
what they gave up
in the james harden deal what they have
to be hoping for
is that the buyout market yields a
player
that fits what they're looking for i
mean every year there seems to be
two or three guys that hit that market
that can make an impact
on a contending team the difference this
year though dan
is that the expansion of the play-in
tournament
is going to make a lot more teams feel
like they're in contention
so if you're a team that's sitting there
at 11th or 12th but you're only a couple
of games back from 9th or 10th
you're going to think all right maybe i
will buy this guy out because
we have a chance to get into the
postseason that could depress
the buyout market and if that happens
that's not good news for the nets yeah
that's an interesting take
i hadn't thought of that but if i'm the
lakers if i'm the sixers if i'm the
bucks or the heat like
like how concerned do you think these
teams
should be and are with what's going on
in brooklyn
uh you know concerned might be too
strong a word you're certainly
watching every game they play to see if
their defense becomes
you know possible enough to catch up
with their offense
um and they don't have to be a top 10
defensive team they just need to be
probably top 15 top half of the nba uh
to be
a championship contender so i i'd be
watching them because
you know look the playoffs comes down to
guys that can get you buckets and the
nets now have three guys
that individually can get you buckets
and that's
an incredibly valuable part of this but
you know
another sidelight here dan is to make to
make big threes work
you've got to have sacrifice kyrie even
alluded to this you know last night
in his media interview after the game
you've got to have guys willing to
sacrifice and somebody in that group
is going to really sacrifice in the way
that chris bosh did and kevin love did
in their time as members of big three
um kyrie would seem to be the guy that
that would need to do that
but i i'm struck by by this about kyrie
i mean kyrie
you know he's he's a quirky guy like you
you should if you're kyrie irving you
should be excited about the possibility
of playing with james hard and kevin
durant maybe he is
he's saying all the right things right
now but you have to remember
kyrie was part of a championship team in
cleveland
and he forced his way out with two years
left in his contract he was part of a
really good team in boston he said he
was going to come back
and then he said you know what i don't
want to do this anymore he wanted to
control
his own destiny badly in the summer of
2019
and he did that he signed with brooklyn
his hometown team in a way
he signed to play with kevin durant his
best friend in the league he he picked
his situation for the first time
in his career and now he's back in a
similar place where he's having
kind his career dictated to him by the
addition of james harden that that
that to me bears watching dan how kyrie
reacts to once again
being in a situation that was not of his
choosing
did we learn anything from his press
conference
just that whatever is going on in his
life is still wearing on him
i mean i'm not uh i i don't like to wait
too deep into the psyche of kyrie irving
and what
um you know what really impacts him and
what doesn't but
you can't watch that press conference
and think that
everything in kyrie's world is okay i
mean he was asked he was okay he just
basically nodded
in the affirmative it's i don't know how
it manifests itself he's if he's able to
push past it to play basketball
at a high level but it's pretty clear
that what pushed kyrie away from the
game in early january
is still lingering with him now what do
you think of the lakers so far
you're almost waiting for any kind of
bump along the way i mean maybe they get
it on this road trip they start a seven
game road trip tonight
uh against milwaukee that'll be a fun
matchup i think
i kind of think in this game dan lebron
and anthony davis go right at
giannis i mean lebron see as you know
like still
remembers every slide against him and it
is still i think
uh bristling a little bit from not
getting as many mvp votes
as he should have had and anthony davis
thought he was defensive player of the
year
last year and not giannis so i think
they're going to go out young is pretty
good
uh in this game tonight but the lakers
just this look i haven't been
in had their their season directed by
covid uh the guys they brought in
have pretty much worked from dennis
schroeder on down and lebron
is playing at an mvp level while i think
playing the fewest minutes per game
uh in his career so it's just they're
not really a story because nothing has
has has slowed their ascent they're
picking up exactly where they left off
last season
quiet is good in laker land as we found
out with frank vogel
quiet is good it leads to championships
uh chris thanks as always for joining us
we appreciate your time bud
you got that that's chris mannix he
covers the nba for sports illustrated
senior writer